my name is george moats and yes i am
your burger scholar
oh
[Music]
my name is george moats and it's my job
to preserve all things hamburger
that's right because you need to
appreciate the hamburger as much as i do
which might be impossible but you'll get
there just keep watching these silly
shows right
okay
here's some good advice from the burger
scholar you want a cheeseburger head to
a college town that's right because
duh
students love cheeseburgers college
towns are famous
for cheeseburgers there's so many of
them around you've got madison wisconsin
great burger town austin texas amazing
burger town nashville tennessee i can
keep going
one has peanut butter on it one has
unmelted cheddar these are very strange
things to have on a burger but
somehow they've endured they have
generations of fans they've been around
in some cases over
70 and 80 years that's a [ __ ] classic
that's true wow i'm like i got i got i
got chills
do you feel it
i'm gonna make you two regional
specialties from the midwest that are
specifically college town burgers the
theta special near the ou campus in
norman oklahoma and the dwayne price
it's not on just hurt i was like you
know
sorry stop laughing
and the dwayne purvis from the xxx
restaurant near purdue university in
west lafayette indiana
yes the theta and the purpose let's do
this oh [ __ ]
say it don't spray it let's start with
the theta when i think of oklahoma i
think of the fried onion burger it's an
iconic
oklahoma burger but there's another one
the theta the theta is even more hyper
regional and beloved by locals it's been
around for over 80 years that's right
this is no joke
i had the same thought it's one of those
burgers that manages to tick all the
boxes with very few ingredients okay
follow me here it's a toasted bun beef
mayo dill pickles some kind of crazy
hickory barbecue sauce and shredded mild
cheddar got everything he needs in there
with very few ingredients here's the
origin story as i've been told
apparently a guy named ralph geist had a
burger joint town tavern that was over
a dance hall near the ou campus a bunch
of different orders were coming in late
night from the kappa alpha theta
sorority on campus all different types
of burgers and was making ralph crazy so
he went to the sorority and he said
girls can we come up with one burger
i'll call it your burger
and the theta special was born over 80
years later you can still find the
burger all over the state specifically
at a place called johnny's in oklahoma
city they still make a theta
who's hungry let's make this okay so i'm
gonna do my favorite ham smash method
where i just press
between two pieces of parchment paper
salt on the patty
next we have toasted butt
oh yeah okay
perfectly toasted wow check that out
ah
[Music]
open that up
should i not
okay that's good we're good
no cheese
normally you'd put cheese in a burger at
this point right
not gonna do it because the cheese
actually goes on cold when it comes off
the flat top
here's a cool trick take a block of
cheddar but use the long side so you
could actually get nice long
strips of cheddar believe it or not
yours truly
basically almost got booted from college
i had to really work my way back in i
kind of forgot that college was about
higher education
and this burger scholar
was not much of a student actually
i made my first film in college
you want to see it it's called keg from
hell it was about a keg
that's at a party and turns on all the
students and kills them one by one
here's keg from hell
i can't believe you're looking at this i
can't believe i'm looking at this
[Music]
okay patty aunty bun
no cheese yet the first ingredient that
goes on
is hickory smoked barbecue sauce
next
a pile look at that oh
a pile of shredded
unmelted cheddar this is really what
they did
then pickles on top of that dill pickles
to cut the fat
mayonnaise
on the inside
the crown of the bun
look at that
mayonnaise pickles
unmelted shredded mild cheddar
hickory sauce and a burger patty on a
toasted
sesame
bun
i mean does this say
i'm good and buzzed at midnight or what
look at that thing
ah
you can see why this is a college town
favorite look at this thing let me take
a bite
on this thing pickle
cheese
barbecue sauce
[Laughter]
so
oh yeah
if it were midnight in norman oklahoma
1937
i would still have sauce on my face and
i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
ah
that burger
is insanely good
and that's exactly why this burger has
been around
for over 80 years i'll see you next time
um i wonder why we're going the next
burger
i'm going to take a nap and come back
and make the next burger
next the dwayne purvis from the xxx
restaurant in west lafayette indiana
right near the purdue campus indiana's
first and oldest drive-in the xxx
restaurant has a bunch of burgers that
are named after famous athletes that
went to purdue
and one of them's very important is the
dwayne purvis number 45 dwayne
purvis
we
dwayne purvis was not only a fullback
for the boilermakers who actually one
year ran 1800 yards in one year he was
also a track star at purdue who was
globally ranked number three in 1933.
whoa not surprisingly the xxx restaurant
right near the campus named a burger
after him it's a unique burger it looks
like a standard cheeseburger but there's
also peanut butter and a very unique
cooking method at the triple x they take
a wad of fresh ground beef and they
throw it into flour see that that's
flour
and they actually hand patty it
push it into a patty in the flour
what's in fact what's happening here is
you end up you're coating it almost like
a schnitzel
basically making a schnitzel burger they
take it and they put it
onto a flat surface they
press it out into the shape of a burger
and throw it on the flat top didn't make
a whole lot of noise did it
there you go so you can imagine what's
going to happen here now
the rendering beef fat is going to
commingle
with the flower
to create a very pronounced
crust
cheese on
oh yeah
triplex started out as a root beer stand
or what was known back in the days of
prohibition as a thirst station they
made their own root beer there was a
time when breweries shifted to making
root beer because they couldn't make
beer during prohibition
and triple x
brand still exists today like you can go
to the triplex restaurant and get
yourself a xxx root beer one of the best
ways to wash down a duane purvis
mother
they take the bottom of the bun the heel
and they take a very
large scoop
actually they use a spatula and they
basically put the peanut butter on to
the bottom of the bun just like that
that's right it's on the bottom next
the patty
lettuce
slice of tomato pickle
and raw onion it's all put together just
like that ah look at that
when you mix beef grease and peanut
butter together
stand back that's a good combination
right there
oh
oh man
ah pickles and peanut butter
my god
thank you duane purvis
thank you for making this hot mess that
we still enjoy
almost 70 years later
[Music]
we learned a lot in this episode we
learned a lot about college town burgers
i didn't learn a whole lot in college
but i did learn a lot
about eating in college
[Music]
that's good
i'll see you next time on burger scholar
sessions
thanks for watching
hi i'm george moats from burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here
right here
up in here